[Music]
one of the things that's really helped
me a lot is I love solving problems and
I believe you know in engineering you
can always solve a problem and I think
that's actually true in business as well
my name is Lisa Sue and I'm CEO of AMD
go of AMD she's an MIT PhD she's a
Taiwanese immigrant and she really saved
this historic Silicon Valley company
bringing it back from the dead and
making it one of the most important chip
companies in the industry
I was born in Taiwan and I came to the
US when I was two with my parents and
you know growing up my father used to
quiz me with math tables at the dining
room table so that's how I first got
into math and when I was young I like to
actually take things apart my brother
had a toy remote controlled car and it
stopped working and I was wondering why
did it stop working and so I opened it
up tried to see what was going on and
there was like a wire that was loose and
and we were able to get it back working
again by putting it back together
I went to the Bronx High School of
Science in New York and I was surrounded
by you know people who loved Math and
Science and Technology I will say there
was a part of me that wanted to be a
concert pianist but I don't think I was
good enough to do that so I ended up
being an engineer
but I was really inspired by when I was
a freshman at MIT is I went into a
semiconductor line for the first time
and I saw how you made chips and that
was just so cool to me that's really how
I ended up being in semiconductors
having a a summer job when I was a first
year college student
I was at IBM in the mid 90s we were
working at the Forefront of
semiconductor devices
semiconductors were so interesting to me
I mean I love the idea that you could
you know really make something that
works you know all of these transistors
these tiny little things that you could
really put together in a chip and so we
worked on some of the newest Innovations
things like copper interconnects and you
know new ways to make devices faster and
and less power and denser
[Music]
those days people
always Moore's Law ending are we not
going to be able to make devices smaller
and and so much of the challenge was how
could we keep increasing performance and
increase in capability while also making
these devices smaller so we could put
more transistors on a single chip so
that was the key thing and we had a
great team that was working on that
I joined AMD in 2012. I always knew
about AMD as a important company in the
industry and was an opportunity to work
on a bigger platform so I was you know
very interested in joining AMD there are
a lot of things happening at that point
in time there was this this whole
revolution of you know where were PCS
going what was happening in Mobile
phones what was going to be the next big
Tech going on so I wanted to be at a
company that really would work at the
bleeding edge of Technology
when Sue came into the role she had this
really gargantuan task ahead of her the
company stock had plummeted a quarter of
the workforce had been laid off and
she's really been able to pull off one
of the greatest turnarounds in Silicon
Valley history
Sue really boiled down her turn around
strategy to three things building great
products focusing on customer relations
and the third thing is simplifying the
company so focusing on strengths like PC
chips and data centers
in the early days when I joined AMD it
was actually about getting customers and
large Partners to trust us and trust
that we could develop the best
technology in the world and that they
could trust their road maps and you know
their business with our technology
you know what I would say is look it's
going to take us five years but we will
be best in class in the industry and
we're going to do it in these three
steps with our news and architecture and
our new microprocessors and so it really
is about a track record and doing what
you say you're going to do and ensuring
that we meet our commitments
the people who know her also points to
this unique mix of technical ability and
people skills and that's kind of what's
Driven her success being able to bring
people together problem solve and focus
on more than just the business
what I've really enjoyed about being an
engineer is really Building Products
that's what I love in life it's really
you know how do you build great products
how do you see where your products go
and you know really make the world a
better place and the role of a CEO you
know that's one piece of it that's not
all pieces of it we have many
stakeholders we have our employees we
have our board our shareholders our
partners and so it's really balancing
not just the technology but also
balancing and ensuring that you know we
are really meeting all of our
stakeholders expectations
the thing about the semiconductors and
you know developing you know chips is
you really do have to make bets three to
five years in advance and you have to
think about okay where is the industry
going and how are we going to bring you
know sort of new ideas to an industry
that really has lots and lots of great
companies and lots of smart people so
you know at AMD we spend a lot of time
thinking about where is technology going
in the future what's going to be really
important what are the limiting factors
and how do we do something that nobody
else can do
I've been in the semiconductor industry
for the last you know 30 years and you
know sort of in the beginning people
didn't really understand what
semiconductors were for they were kind
of like underneath the surface you know
you knew something about chips and
something about computers but not
exactly you know why they were important
I think what's been amazing over the
last few decades and especially even
over the last three or four years people
Now understand that semiconductors are
essential like you need chips in
everything that you do in every part of
your life and every part of the business
and every part of how we deliver you
know great health care and you know
great technology and great capabilities
and I think that's what makes it cool is
that you know semiconductors are now
something that everyone thinks about as
being super important for our daily
lives
foreign
we love seeing our products and
Technologies really make a difference in
everyone's lives I'm not sure I'm ready
to talk about Legacy I think we have a
lot to do right now to continue pushing
the envelope on technology touching
billions of people with AMD technology
would be a wonderful thing
[Music]
foreign